- Hi, I'm Ella Morton, I'm a
senior editor at Atlas Obscura,
and there's nothing I like
more on an autumnal afternoon
than hanging out in a graveyard.
I will gladly do so alone, if I must,
but today I am very lucky
to be joined by someone
of like mind, Caitlin Doughty.
- You're not alone today, Ella.
- Yes, I have friends it's wonderful.
Caitlin is a mortician
and a funeral expert
and we are just going to discuss
the special nature of
this particular cemetery.
We are in Bushwick, Brooklyn.
This is the Most Holy Trinity Cemetery.
It was founded in 1851 as
a German Catholic graveyard
at a time when bodies were being dug up
out of Manhattan burial
grounds and (whooshing noise)
shifted over to Brooklyn
because it was getting too overcrowded.
But the main special
thing about this cemetery
is that the gravestones
are not made of stone.
They're made of metal.
- Bum bum ba.
- And that's really cool.
And we're going to talk
about how that came to be
and what the consequences have been.
So first obvious question,
why are the headstones metal?
- Why metal?
Originally the idea was
really quite lovely.
The idea was that everyone
whether you were rich or you were poor,
you would get the same style
and material for your
headstones, either wood or metal.
And while this was a lovely idea,
what's happened over the last 165 years
is that they have crumbled,
they have oxidized
and it doesn't look quite
the same as it once did.
- [Ella] As we've been
walking around we've seen
headstones in various states of disarray.
Some have crumbled and rusted
and sort of crumpled in on themselves
but they weren't always like that.
- You'll notice right now,
there are these big empty spaces
in the cemetery like where we're sitting.
They didn't used to be empty.
This cemetery used to
be packed to the gills
with wooden headstones, metal headstones
that over time and in the elements
have largely rotted away.
- And all of these wooden
and metal headstones and
monuments, they all looked
brand spanking new at one point?
- Well, not only did the
headstones, the metal ones,
look new, they looked like stone.
They were deceptive headstones
because they painted them this gray color
which ended up looking like
they were made of granite.
- [Ella] Deceptive.
- Yeah, sneaky, sneaky German Catholics.
(laughter)
- So if you came to this cemetery,
if you saw it from a
distance it would just look
like any other cemetery of the time?
- Well, they would look normal-ish.
So again, these were German
Catholics and at the time
they had different iconography
than was popular in Protestant cemeteries.
So Protestant cemeteries you
had a much tamer view of death
we're talking urns and obelisks,
where the German Catholics
were still going all out
with sparkly crucifixes
and cherubs and lambs.
So you would come into
a cemetery like this,
there was a reporter who did
in the late 19th century,
and was horrified by all
of the three-foot-tall
crucified, tortured
Christs in the cemetery
and he said that this
was an aesthetic failure
of the cemetery.
So it was just a very different vibe
at a Catholic cemetery than
it would be somewhere else.
- If you're used to urns,
then a giant tortured Christ
is a bit of a departure.
- ...is maybe not, wouldn't
be your first choice.
- Wow, so it's German Catholic
that was a little bit
different, what about customs?
- So since it was German
they would have German verses
that were spelled out on the monuments.
My understanding is
that when children died,
the parents would come
and leave playthings
and leave toys at the graves,
which is something that
parents still do today
in cemeteries if they allow it.
And it's a custom that I
was really fascinated by.
Apparently the gravedigger
would go into the grave
and fill the grave with the family there
and there would be a
call-and-response prayer
not with the priest in the family,
but the gravedigger in the family.
- I love that.
I feel like gravediggers
get overlooked in general.
- And I like it because
it's like a visceral...
- Yeah, audience participation.
- Audience participation,
call-and-response,
when I say "Dead" you say "My mom."
Yeah, me someday.
- I like it, yeah, nice memento mori.
What about the more dark side?
What about the depravity?
Was there crime here?
- There certainly was crime.
You can notice that even
now there's an isolation
to the cemetery, you have
the subway running overhead,
it feels isolated even in
this growing neighborhood.
The idea of the metal
monuments is supposed to be
this egalitarian idea and
it's supposed to be lovely
and all that but it
actually led to problems
because metal is so
easy to come in, steal,
and then sell for scrap.
- [Ella] So we talked
about how it causes decay
and there's a lot of
headstones around the place
that are crumbling,
but I actually like the
way that that looks.
It creates these new sculptural objects
that are beautiful in their own way.
- [Caitlin] There's so
many older cemeteries
with granite headstones
and granite monuments
that look pretty similar
no matter where you go, no
matter what you're looking at
and each sculptural object, like you said,
here at Most Holy Trinity
is unique in a way
and I think it's beautiful.
- Me too.
There's beauty in the decay.
- Oh, you're after my own heart.
(laughter)
- So thank you for spending time with us
in the graveyard today.
If you're interested in even more details
on these gravestones,
what they're made of,
how they weathered and crumbled,
Caitlin made another video on her channel,
Ask a Mortician, so head there to see it.
What do I say now?
- You say thank-
I think you're just too
classy a person, Ella,
to do a proper YouTube outro
you have to like look at the camera
and be like all right Obscurians,
I need you to smash that
like and subscribe button,
I'll see you next week.
Tweet, retweet, Facebook, Instagram, uh...
- Socials.
- We're out, all the socials.
Atlas out.
There we go, we learned a lot today.
- Well.
- Your training is complete, padawan.